our last speaker of the day but not the
least is hamsa vastani she's a an
assistant professor at the Wharton
School at 10 and she will tell us about
her fascinating work in healthcare
I don't know about fascinating but I'll
try to entertain you guys because this
is the last hour so thanks for coming
back uh this is doing work with a lot of
people uh I'll highlight Osborne and pen
and Angel Chung and uh who's my PhD
student at Wharton who have been doing a
lot of the technical work uh but we've
been very reliant on a bunch of folks
from macro guys which is a startup that
angel and I both consult at so the heat
is a data scientist there Musa is
actually our boots on the ground in
Sierra Leone which is where all of this
is being implemented Ashley Schmidt is a
deployment manager and Lauren Sandy is
the head of the national medical
supplies agency in the Sierra Leone so
he's the big boss that we report to
um so I'll be talking about basically
they said the problem that we have is uh
how do we distribute essential medicines
in Sierra Leone given a very limited
inventory so on a quarterly basis uh
Sierra Leone which is one of the poorest
countries in the world actually uh gets
a limited inventory from organizations
like usaid on uh essential medicines
like amoxicillin or jadelle so there are
about 100 plus essential medicines and
they're tasked with sort of Distributing
them across a thousand plus Health
Facilities that they have uh so these
points here are health facilities and
they're actually colored by the type of
facility but of course I didn't put a
legend in there uh basically these might
be hospitals District medical stores you
know what have you uh and already you
can see kind of this is the capital of
Sierra Leone which is Freetown and you
can see there's a very high density of
points here uh and then as we go to the
northern regions which are even more
impoverished than sort of your average
uh Sierra Leone population uh Things
become even more scattered you can see
low density so a lot lot of equity
concerns here which uh we're hoping to
look at soon so the problem is basically
that there's highly uncertain demand and
you have very limited budgets uh and so
a lot of the needs are not being
fulfilled yes
what is population density like like
those where those empty areas at the top
do people live there or is it just okay
yeah it's very hard to measure
population density in Sierra Leone
because the census is kind of suspect so
we're in the process of getting that
data if you look at Night Lights of
satellite data it's basically very dark
except at Freetown but there are
definitely people living here which Musa
tells us uh so you know there is quite a
lot of population in the provinces but
most of the population is concentrated
here but they have more access to
resources but great question
other questions before I
well uh so the goal is kind of generally
like oh can we you know use machine
learning and optimization to do better
and hopefully the answer is yes if not
that would be sad uh and so let me tell
you a little bit about what they're
doing right now and so like how we can
improve upon this right uh so the
current approach is basically each of
these Health Facilities will put in a
request which is a three-month rolling
average of their demand so I will say
already this is very problematic because
there's a lot of missing data especially
in the more impoverished regions uh and
so the how you take this rolling average
is sort of very very sensitive uh but
then once you do this they actually plug
this into a very complex Excel
allocation tool which if you've taught
an MBA course you've probably seen
things like this and told your students
not to do it right
um so basically this thing has like 32
different tabs uh and the reason is
because they started off with some
Global health-based solution uh and then
they realized okay we actually need to
add population and poverty modifiers so
they added tabs for that uh and then
they decided we should prioritize
hospitals over other health facilities
so they added more decision rules for
that and so you basically have this like
um conglomeration of decision rules
um but they're not really cognizant of
what happened before so we're just
adding these rules as we go along
without you know being re-realizing
what's happening before
um and I think Angel my student is the
only person who completely understands
how this tool works because she
re-implemented it in Python and she
actually found like two serious bugs in
that they were referencing the wrong
column another reason why you should not
use Excel to build these tools uh and so
we're not really competing with a super
strong Baseline but I'll tell you that
it's still hard to do better uh there's
more inefficiency that comes out of the
fact that they basically have this like
three-step process so this is where the
national medical supplies agency Works
uh again Freetown uh and so they get a
bunch of stock and so we'll see like uh
they'll decide to allocate them between
the different types of stores or like
hospitals and then they decide to
allocate them across districts are
different locations that are like macro
locations and then there's yet another
human decision maker who then comes in
and decides how to allocate it uh for
facilities within the districts right
and so we're really breaking up this
decision process which again is a source
of inefficiency if you're doing
optimization right uh so what we were
tasked with at macaroids was kind of to
say okay if we were to if we had the
ability to rebuild this whole system
from scratch like what would we do right
uh oh I forgot to mention so these are h
essential medicine like vocal products
that we're looking at uh and on the
y-axis is the total unfulfilled request
uh in a representative month uh and you
can see it's quite High the average
unfulfilled demand across the country is
about 42 percent right so we're like in
a fairly
um Supply not meeting demand sort of
scenario right uh and that's why this
problem is interesting like in the US I
don't think we have this problem as much
um except for the whole generic drug
shortage which is a whole other thing uh
okay so if we were doing this from
scratch what would we do we could think
about doing predict and optimize right
so like in the first step maybe I train
a demand prediction model for every
Health product uh at every health
facility and then I take those estimates
and I plug them into some stochastic
optimization problem that is then going
to actually make allocations right uh
this is a very popular and practical
approach uh and there's basically been a
whole and a stream of research on
end-to-end learning saying this is not
really efficient because the predictive
models being trained to minimize means
Square to error which is blind to the
fact that it's being plugged into a
stochastic optimization problem so you
should somehow train these models to
account for the optimization problem uh
and that's kind of what we're looking at
as well
foreign
so like if we're doing learning and
optimization we get a response wise so
this thing is maybe today's demand uh I
want to compute a decision Z which is
maybe like how much inventory I want to
allocate to minimize some like known
decision loss right so this is a classic
problem and of course the issue is that
I don't actually know why right I'm
predicting these optimization parameters
why based on some historical covariates
like historical demand or something like
that uh and what like you know modern
data science has given us is that this
step can be very very complex and it can
be non-differentiable let's say if
you're using random force or something
like that so we wanted we want to kind
of allow large complexity here uh but at
the same time we want to make sure that
we can optimize this right so what would
happen in a typical problem I'll get a
training phase where I'll get some
examples or historical data x i y i star
I train some function f data this could
be anything to minimize some loss so I
won't say what El tilde is for now but
like in a standard workflow this would
be like mean squared error and then in a
testing phase I would get my new x i
form a prediction F data that's this is
my predict uh and then I stick it into
my uh optimization problem to get Z star
of Y hat y hat because you know that's
what I predicted uh and then I optimized
right
uh and so the key question we'll be
talking about is what prediction lost L
tilde we should be using in training
this prediction problem right so if I
didn't care about the decision law at
all or the optimization problem I would
just use mean square right so this is
what all the data scientists like I
think impractice currently do
um so I just you look at why hack minus
y star squared if I want it to be
perfectly aware of the optimization loss
then I would say okay that's not my loss
my loss is really you know the loss of Z
star of Y hat like the decision I made
uh with Y hat uh like the objective of
that optimization problem right uh and
this is really nasty because that V-Star
itself is a minimizer of the
optimization loss this thing is
non-convex flat in lots of places and
highly non-smooth and you can't really
minimize this which is why people
haven't right
foreign
cool so originally my intuition which
generally is quite bad was that um if I
build a really good predictive model and
I stick it into my optimization that
should be as well as I can realistically
do like why would I ever want to like
change how I train my predictive model
because of this optimization problem and
my co-authors had no problem with
intuition but I did so I'm going to give
you uh what sort of convinced me that
this actually does matter uh and this
example is actually based on the Sierra
Leone setting so I think this actually
happens for us so imagine that you have
two kinds of facilities like
well-stocked facilities like the ones in
Freetown and then the poorly stocked
facilities that are maybe in the north
and my goal is to allocate new inventory
to meet demand in the next quarter right
so now I have this uh this toy example
uh so basically this is my prior
inventory and then this is sort of the
demand I'm going to realize this quarter
uh and you can see that the true
function is kind of piecewise linear so
it's the green line for the poorly
stocked facility so the ones that have
low prior inventory and then it's a red
line for uh the highly the well-stocked
facilities that have this larger
inventory right uh and because I don't
really know what's going on and just
data is kind of noisy I'm just going to
go ahead and fit a linear function not a
piecewise linear function so I'm going
to fit this blue line here so this blue
line is my decision blind kind of model
because it sort of just says okay I'm
going to fit the best predictive model I
can and you can see it's actually not
bad if I were to visually look at this
without showing you the piecewise linear
functions you might actually be full to
thinking that actually does look kind of
linear like a good fit right
and now we have a really weird scenario
where there's actually no point this
could be pretty bad because the red
points here are constructed such that
there's actually no point predicting
well on them right because they're
already well stocked so in my next
quarter I'm not going to send them any
inventory anyway right so from a
decision-making perspective
predicting well here like small
perturbations here is like uh it's not
it doesn't matter I'm still gonna send
them nothing because they already have
the stock they need but if you look at
the teal coins that's not true right I'm
trying to match the Y and demand because
I'm in this really limited budget
setting so for every extra thing unit
that I predict I'm going to send them an
extra unit of product uh and so I really
really want to nail my demand prediction
here I don't care whether I get my
Demand right here locally right uh and
this is true even as like my sample size
goes to Infinity I mean uh like this
decision blind model this blue one is
going to be like arbitrarily mispecified
for the facilities I care about uh and
so this is always going to be a bad
policy right instead while I could have
done is just use this teal line right if
I just built a local linear model here I
would have been totally fine
does this make sense
cool so uh stepping back what are we
interested in in terms of this like
building pipeline we want something
that's like fairly General so we wanted
to be able to interface with like fairly
complex data science and convex
optimization pipelines this is important
because um I'll show you that this is
actually a pretty hard data science
problem that uh the data scientist that
he'd worked on for like about six months
so we can't really touch it too much uh
and then we also want it to be
computationally tractable so and by that
I just mean like run within a few hours
and uh some of the existing work doesn't
uh and we also want it to be light touch
enough that it doesn't significantly
alter data science workflows I'll show
you what that means in a minute
okay uh so let me talk about prior work
a little bit so I think uh Demetrius
bertsimas and Nathan callus had one of
the early works on trying to combine
like sort of machine learning and
optimization stochastic optimization
specifically uh so they basically talked
about clustering nearby observations in
the X space using cart or lowest to
estimate this conditional distribution y
given X so you could put it in an SAA
problem uh so this is uh this is the
case they don't actually update the
predictive model or how the predictive
model is trained based on the
optimization problem so this is more
about learning this conditional
distribution for SAE uh what we are
interested about uh is actually being
able to get a predictive model that's
more tailored for the decision loss uh
and this also turns out to not be
computationally intractable Beyond like
simple models like cart uh but Nathan
actually came along and wrote a
follow-up paper with the student Xiao ji
Mao on a more specialized approach that
does alter the predictive model and is
also more computationally tractable for
random forest and stochastic so for
example average approximation uh so this
one actually like the issue is that it's
not very general uh so basically it
needs a one-to-one match between the
predictive model and the optimization
problem that you're solving so it's like
these news vendor type problems uh and
what we have is basically
um a meta learning problem so we need to
learn across multiple facilities or
multiple products at the same time I'll
show you that's actually critical to
being able to get any predictive
accuracy at all uh and so we want
something that's sort of more General
and doesn't fit like a specific problem
formula uh and also this is also turns
out to be not that computation
interactable because every tree split in
your random Forest requires resolving
the optimization problem which kind of
quickly got out of hand in our setting
um and then there's this really nice
paper by uh Adam and Paul which
basically solves this problem in the
case of linear predictions and the lp
loss uh I really really like this paper
if you haven't read it you should read
it
um but this strategy is kind of very
specific to linear models they basically
offer a surrogate loss function that
approximates L tilde quite nicely even
though it's strongly convex uh but that
wouldn't work for like a random forest
or when your uncertainties and your
constraints which is what we will have
uh and then finally Brian Wilder and
Mill and tombe have been doing kind of a
series of work on being able to back
propagate through the decision loss so
this requires this is like somewhat
specific I think to neural Nets or other
differential function classes and you
also need to solve the optimization
problem at every gradient step so it's
kind of also not computation intractable
but honestly I don't care about any of
these things to me like from a practical
standpoint all these methods require you
to re-implement like classic machine
learning packages and there is no way
we're going to be able to get our data
scientists to do that I mean they've
spent years perfecting you know their
scient or tensorflow little skills and
you know there's a lot of bells and
whistles in these packages that we like
can't reasonably re-implement right so
uh my whole thing has been like let's
have a really light touch change where
we can you know slightly alter this
predictive loss maybe it's not optimal
but you know it will get us kind of
closer to that optimization loss that we
care about
questions
I'm so thirsty today I don't know why uh
okay so partly I set this example up to
kind of foreshadow like what you might
do so if you looked at this you probably
thought maybe I should just re-weight my
data right and if you didn't think that
let's pretend you thought that
um so let's say that you have these
Baseline predictions y hat right that is
that I'm getting from my blue line here
this is my decision blind model
um and I want to basically say like I
was saying these red dots these
well-stocked facilities they don't
really matter for my optimization loss
these teal triangle points they really
matter for my optimization loss so if we
could just learn which ones are
important then we can uh then where you
know you're cooking with what is this
thing cooking with fire
yeah thank you uh we can get weights for
these observations based on the
importance to improving the decision
loss near y hat right and I'll show you
how to do that it's actually quite
straightforward you tailor expand
l-tilda and you take the first order
term uh and that actually basically
gives you weight so I'll show you that
in a second but once you get these
weights it's actually very easy right
you optimize your weighted loss using
any off-the-shelf machine learning
package to get decision aware
predictions so basically I would give
these guys a weight of one and these
guys are weight of like Epsilon or
something small right and then I'm fine
and then I would get this teal line and
the teal line is actually a pretty good
predictor locally I don't care about how
badly I predict over there right that's
basically the idea
cool so how do we actually get the
weights so we take this L uh of Z star
of y y star and we tailor expand around
the decision line loss y hat uh and so
this first or a zeroth order term here
is just a constant we drop it then we
look at this first order term right so
the first order term has two
coefficients so one is the effect of the
prediction on the decision so like how y
affects Z star and then the other one is
the effect of the decision on the
decision law so how sensitive is my
optimization objective to Z itself right
um and so these two you can kind of
think of as weights because now I have
my y minus y hat uh which is my typical
error right it's not signed but I'll get
to it in a second uh but you have this
uh this coefficient that doesn't depend
on Theta or the parameter that I'm
actually using to minimize the loss uh
and so we can rewrite our prediction
model objective as this uh and basically
here I've added these the absolute
values to make sure that it doesn't you
know because this thing only holds
locally but we there's a reason we
Square our mean squared error so as a
heuristic we've just kind of added the
absolute values and then these are kind
of the weight so the magnitude of the
weight is what we hope will capture how
much this point matters to the loss of Z
ha z z of Y star uh y hat right
um and so typically you won't be able to
compute these gradients analytically
I'll show you that for the Sierra Leone
setting because we have a fairly simple
stochastic optimization problem you can
compute them analytically or at least as
what can I put it
but in general you can compute them
numerically using like uh prior work by
others
um like Stephen Boyd and SQL filter
foreign okay so what is our strategy we
train an arbitrary decision blind Model
F Theta of x uh we compute gradients
through some arbitrary optimization
problem using off the shelf techniques
to get our training data weights uh and
then we retrain the model with the
weighted training data so any kind of
predictive model like we'll take a
vector of weights for the training
points uh and so this is easy and then
we rerun the optimization problem with
plug-in estimates right so this is
really very very simple lightweight
strategy uh so first of all it's General
and that it only requires re-weighting
the observation so even if you're doing
meta learning or anything complicated
that's totally fine right we're not
really touching the data
um second of all it's very
computationally tractable because we
only run the optimization problem twice
and we only train the predictive model
twice you could do it K times if you
felt the if you felt like you wanted to
but you wouldn't have to do it for every
gradient step or every tree split which
is a lot more and then finally there's
no re-implementation right you can just
Supply these weights very easily in fact
we did and our data scientist was happy
so that was our objective function uh
and this sort of extends
straightforwardly to offline
reinforcement learning if you were to
swap the optimization objective with a
cost to go function or something like
that offline not online I don't know I
think that's an interesting open problem
cool uh that's all the math I have
before I jump into the actual
application does anyone have any
questions
okay so
um the products that we were looking at
before we went to deployments so there's
a little bit of a mismatch here I'll
show you uh but um we basically looked
at eight focal products that they said
um were had like reasonably high quality
demand data uh and so this was uh some
for children uh some for maternal health
and some for family planning so
generally in many countries in Africa
these are the kinds of products that are
donated as essential medicines because
uh people want to Target you know
pregnant women and young kids right
uh and so the data we Source from dhis2
forms so like a lot of medical centers
like a lot of this data is still done by
hand but then there's this open source
tool that's been adopted by a lot of
countries in Africa uh called the dhis2
where they actually digitize like health
planning data at a monthly level so we
have this from Jan 29 to July 2021. uh
one big challenge is that there's a huge
number of missing values so if you look
at early on in the time series the
percentage of missing values is
basically 100 right uh so nobody there
were forms but nobody was filling them
out classic uh kind of like the covert
forms at Penn and then after some time
like basically the nmsa started yelling
at them Ministry of Health was reading
down to the next so it started like
going down over time so people were
actually filling out the forms and then
it kind of plateaued because the people
that you know are super stubborn you're
not going to get convinced them anyway
right uh so lots of missing data I think
partly this is a hard problem uh and
then we also have lots of a Time series
right so like every health facility
product pair is one time series right uh
and so if even if we're just looking at
the eight products so we actually
started looking at the full 100 set now
but even we're just looking at eight and
we're looking at a thousand facilities
you're talking about like 9 000 plus
time series but each of them only has 18
observations right because we only had
31 months to begin with and then like
half of it is missing anyway uh so
that's not great uh but you can see that
if you look at some of these smooth time
series there does seem to be like
systematic like cross-facility
correlations this isn't like a very
smooth process uh so there does seem to
be value in kind of doing some
forecasting
uh and so Standard Time series
forecasting with 18 observations going
to do very poorly like duh right and do
not need to tell you that okay so what
can you do you can do meta learning so
like let's say that you have a Time
series for one product and one health
facility uh well okay I can't do
anything with that but I actually have
lots of health facilities thousand plus
uh for the same product so I can kind of
try to learn across that uh and then on
top of that if I have facility specific
Pizza facts well I have lots of products
in each health facility so maybe I can
try to learn along this Dimension as
well right and you can imagine maybe
it's like a tensor completion type of
problem okay uh that actually didn't
work that well for us so we ended up
doing a random Forest but the idea is
basically that we have a proxy data from
other facilities and other products and
we can use this to kind of reduce
variance right uh so like if I were
training a linear model if I just use
insisted on using the data from my
target predictive task I'm going to have
a ton of variants if I throw in data
from like other health facility these
are products I'm going to have bias but
less variance and then this whole idea
of meta learning which is something
we've been working on for a while is to
kind of be able to trade off bias and
variants and do better right
um and so the way that we did this here
was a lot of hand engineering that our
data scientists did
um so there's like a bunch of lag
demands for each product and that
facility for the last 10 months uh month
in year fixed effects rolling average
for the last few months the variance and
facility region and type and stuff like
that so you throw all this in
um and after a lot of iteration and
mutation and feature cleaning and things
like that uh we were able and the
outcome here is that the demand for a
product facility pair at like a Time T
right so how did this work like well if
not uh we wouldn't have been able to
work with the nmsa so uh this is the
marketing comms uh plot by macro ice
obviously I didn't make it because it's
not ggplot
um but basically this pink bar here so
on the x-axis you have the eight
products the pink bar is the three month
rolling average forecasting error that
they're using after we fix the bug uh in
their Excel sheet uh and then the green
bars kind of the macro guys like random
forest model so this is still a decision
blind model this has nothing to do I
haven't even shown you an optimization
problem yet uh and then this yellow bar
is the Improvement relative to the pink
part so this is just like the value of
like you know data and machine learning
or what have you right uh so you can see
that it actually improved the demand
forecast by about 34 to 59 uh on a held
out test set month uh so the nmsa got
very excited about that and they were
like cool we can use machine learning
let's use it for allocations right uh so
this was sort of the in uh so now we
actually want to do optimization right
so how do we optimize this so this is a
bare bone stochastic optimization
problem I always emphasize it because
people are like why can't you put in all
these other things and we want to put in
other things but we don't have the data
to put in other things so we're just
going with the simplest possible
objective but
um so my goal is to allocate make
allocations across all n facilities
right so let's call that an star that
minimizes some cost and I'm just going
to say the cost is uh unmet Demand right
so the first order there's lots of costs
but the first order cost that I care
about is a kid showing up uh to my
health facility and I don't have enough
medication to dispense to them right so
any demand that I can't meet uh in this
situation is terrible uh and so the loss
function is going to be you know CN
which is what I think the demand is the
sample demand uh mine is the current
inventory SN uh minus a n which is like
what I allocated them and we're going to
take a Max with respect to zero so what
if I Overstock I'm kind of fine with
that except that we have a really
stringent budget constraint right so
there's a fixed budget b saying that the
sum of all the ands has to be less than
or equal to B so if I give something to
you know Daniel I can't give it to Irene
and so that sucks right
Daniel's okay with that
um
each facility also cannot hold more than
its capacity
right so there's also like storage space
especially for the vaccine problem
there's like Refrigeration constraints
and things like that that we need to
think about
okay and then I said this is a
stochastic optimization problem how uh
I'm gonna draw we're just doing some
stuff so we're going to draw random
demands at each facility based on the
estimated distribution uh like I told
you we fit a random Forest so we just
take um for each point the distribution
across the 500 or so trees we treat that
as a distribution
box questions
in our data set is a demand sensor that
is an excellent question so in principle
theoretically no because they're
supposed to record everyone who sort of
comes in and you know needs the medicine
and didn't get one because like this
whole three-month rolling average only
makes sense if it's not censored
in practice I think it is censored uh
but not perfectly
so we're doing a bunch of things now to
try to uncensor it
um so like in Ops this would be like
Inventory management with lost sales or
whatever right uh so that is what we're
trying to do uh but for now we are just
dropping any observations where we
believe there is censoring and then
hoping that it extrapolates well and
then trying to introduce some optimism
basically to correct for that uh I think
this doesn't matter so much for
performance but it matters a lot for
Equity so that's sort of our next goal
and that's an excellent question yeah
with respect to equity uh you do treat
basically every loss demand the same
right so in a sense if
you don't like would there be value in
basically saying in some locations in
the wealth stocked ones
lost sale it's a rare event anyway so we
we penalize it less yeah I think that's
very hard to convince a policy maker
that one person is worth less than
another person but I think uh we try to
do this like Oscar tried using like a c
bar objective so that we know we drew a
quantile because we basically have
higher uncertainty for these like less
uh poorly stocked places and weirdly it
actually did worse uh so that's
something we're still trying to like
engineer around with so I'm not going to
pretend that this is anywhere close to
the optimal thing that you could be
doing uh but at least a lot of the
simple things that we try and like c bar
like didn't work that well
um
but yeah I agree with you uh they're
very opposed to re-rating on Med demand
except by uh facility so like Hospital
unmet demand is weighted more than
District medical store on Med demand but
because there is a sense that you know
it's like one country and one people
like you're what you're taking from one
person goes to another person it has to
be like an uncertainty based argument
but that's a weird question
other thoughts
cool so this is an efficient linear
program
people know how to do this Ops 101 okay
um cool so why I brought this up was
because um like I mentioned you can
actually analytically compute what our
weights will end up being in this like
very simple optimization problem uh and
so if you actually do this like remember
I told you that we're going to minimize
the loss where we have like you know the
absolute value difference of the
prediction minus uh so they're a k so
there's two sums here the training data
and also the scenario that I sampled in
uh and you can see that the weight
actually turned out to be something
really intuitive uh which is whether the
demand actually exceeds you know like
the inventory plus the allocation so
basically was this a facility that was
understocked right so we are basically
up waiting training examples that have
unmet demand this is an indicator but
you should really think about it as a
probability because like it's over the
samples K so if you sample over it you
kind of get this like empirical
distribution if you will right uh so
it's very intuitive at least uh you know
this is what sort of convinced me at
least that this is like not an insane
thing to do uh so the idea is basically
that classic machine learning kind of
spends capacity predicting at facilities
uh that have low stock out like you
likelihood because it treats all the
training data the same uh but you know
there are some samples that sort of
matter more for the decisions that we're
making and so they're relevant to the
optimization objective and so we want to
upload these things right uh and so like
I mean you've probably seen this in like
recommender systems for example there
are super users and like sparser users
and like typically if you just do like
collaborative filtering uh you don't
treat your sparse user as well uh and so
they update the sparse you users uh here
we're basically learning what those
weights should be because given an
arbitrary optimization problem you might
not be able to figure it out so quickly
okay how did this work it actually
worked pretty well
um to my surprise uh so these are the
eight essential medicines that I talked
about again these are the ones that have
like good data I'll show you what
happened when we
um went to the ones that have bad data
uh so the green bar is basically the
decision blind uh unmet demand so
basically all we're doing here is we're
training that decision line random Force
plugging into the optimization problem
and getting allocations and then for the
decision aware policy we basically then
do that extra step where we then compute
the weights retrain the random Force
using the exact same Pipeline and then
plug it back into the optimization
problem uh and here we're looking at
unmet Demand on a fixed Budget on a held
out test set month right so we basically
see the true demands we fix a policy and
then we see how well we would have done
in terms of unmet demand uh and you can
see that um they're systematically like
across the board you get a lot of
improvements on the optimization
objective of course if you look at means
where error you do worse but that was
our goal all we care about the
optimization objective and you can see
for like products like magnesium sulfate
so the thing about magnesium sulfate um
I'm not a physician but uh it's
basically like a fairly erratic demand
pattern uh and so this is just something
that's like very hard to forecast and
when it's hard to forecast the
improvement from doing the decision on
where forecasting is also less
uh we also tried these on vaccines so
the three vaccines they were looking at
were BCG measles and pentavalent uh here
we also help but not as much and that is
because for vaccines the demand pattern
is kind of more smooth than essential
meds uh and so it's just an easier task
as you can see for the y-axis the unmet
demand like percentages are kind of just
one smaller uh than they are normally
are for essential limbs
okay questions before I yes
so it seems at least a little bit like
the fundamentally the problem is
actually not as much scarcity of
resources in the sense of like you do
have enough resources it's really about
allocation of resources is that correct
yes and that's actually by Design
because they sum up all the demands
across locations and that's how they
decide how much to donate so you should
imagine that we're always in a situation
where the amount that you're getting at
nfsa like almost exactly matches how
much they think is needed throughout the
country uh and so any mistakes you make
in sending things where they should go
um are like very detrimental so
absolutely yeah
um so if I think back to your piecewise
linear example from the beginning yeah I
could think okay well if you are
training a linear classifier you have to
do the waiting but if you were trading
at you know a piecewise linear
classifier you could get away without
waiting yes could you get away without
waiting with a bigger battery random
forest or would that have other
detrimental effects I think so so I
think that's why we don't help as much
with vaccines because like prediction is
easy whereas for essential medicines
prediction is really really hard because
we have so few observations uh so I
think you're really hitting the nail on
the head but like my intuition only
extends to linear so I was like all
right I'm not touching your Beyond here
uh but I think absolutely so if I had a
perfect predictive model that I wouldn't
need to do any waiting right because it
would perform well in all regions of the
X space all we're doing is saying some
regions of the covariate space matter
more but if you could just get low error
everywhere then you're done right so yes
absolutely your internship
friends
cool so then
um they told us hey we should do this
for the last quarter of 2022 and we
weren't that ready but we did something
um and so this was for
um so in Gray bars here basically we see
the nms's allocation Tool uh and in the
blue bar is basically like what we
Market is the macro ice AI Optimizer uh
and on the x-axis where whatever
products they actually had
um uh stock for for this particular
quarter
um and you can see that generally you
see a lot of gray bars and you don't see
that many blue bars so that's us doing
well we're not getting as much unmet
demand uh and almost everywhere we
actually improve except for rental dopa
where we
um do terribly so we have 79 on Mid
demand and the the you the the crappy
Excel allocation tool that she had zero
percent on net demand so as with any
good engineer we saw this and we took
method open threw it out and we only
deployed it for the other products but
basically this kind of underscores this
issue that like you know so like overall
you can reduce about 84 of unmet demand
at hospitals and 30s so these are the
prioritized facilities and 38 of unmed
demand at uh the other like District
medical store type facilities but
clearly there's like work left to do in
trying to like Smooth out these
predictive models right so Random
forests are like highly erratic and so
they do really well on average but like
occasionally they're off by like a
factor of 100 which is like what
happened here uh so we're working on you
know trying to use this um tool called
catalytic priors that uh Sam coo and Don
Rubin kind of worked on at Harvard to
try to basically use some synthetic data
or like population-based data to smooth
out these predictions it's almost like
doing empirical base but like for random
course uh so that you know like that
doesn't happen right uh but at the very
least like it seems promising on other
kind of products
uh and so this is sort of the map for
the deployment like everybody likes
looking at maps and not Excel tools
don't use Excel kids
um but this is sort of the dashboard and
basically you know you can they can
click on it and say like okay
amoxicillin this is the projected demand
is this the standard area
uh and the goal is to kind of not just
do this first year Leon but it also
deployed in like Cote d'Ivoire and uh
DRC and so on so they have similar
problems like thinking Cote d'Ivoire
they're doing like just a family
planning products and in uh DRC they're
doing essential medicines also uh and so
hopefully there's also opportunity to
kind of transfer learn across countries
because the DRC has about 10 times the
population that Sierra Leone has so with
larger scale is hopefully higher quality
data right so there's opportunities to
kind of learn across
uh I think there's a lot more exciting
questions here than we answered
um so like the first one is the one I
already mentioned like how to stabilize
predictions for these low data products
so we didn't get a chance to like do
that yet but like some kind of catalytic
prior what like what Reuben and others
are working on but like in this
multitask kind of metal learning setting
um and then also like this missing data
has been a really tough problem and it
has all this Equity implications because
they're like systematically missing and
more impoverished locations they think
this is like a very important problem
even sort of in the US like Central
Molina then Seattle obermeyer written
about how you know you might have errors
in terms of diagnosis or like
completeness of the medical record for
poor uh sub populations uh and we have
an opportunity to actually collect this
information right so like you have boots
on the ground you can actually send
people to health facilities and ask them
like what was your demand for this
product just because they didn't fill
out the form doesn't mean we can't do
anything right uh so this is like an
active learning type problem but you
want to do it in a way that like again
is cognizant of the optimization problem
right like so how do you do this
systematically to improve like decision
aware learning uh or Equity objective in
this decision we're a learning kind of
problem
um and then of course like there's a
forward-looking like I've been talking
about this like it's a One-Shot problem
I believe that it actually is just a
one-track problem because there's a lot
of waste and theft uh in these locations
so it's not like inventory perfectly
carries over to the next quarter if you
over allocate uh but in general you
might think of this as a reinforcement
learning problem right uh where you want
to be forward-looking as well uh and
then finally like these forecasts are
actually being used by other
organizations other than the Sierra
Leone nmsa uh so for example mpharma is
a company that actually does like stocks
Pharmaceuticals like in Sierra Leone and
other countries like uh in Africa uh and
so they actually use these demand
forecasts to decide like how much to
stock in each store uh and so I think in
a lot of tech companies we have the same
thing right like where one team is kind
of doing machine learning and the other
team is kind of using those predictions
as a feature or something else uh inside
their decision making problem so there's
this problem of like um if I only know
if I don't know the exact optimization
problem but I had some prior and how
they're making decisions I might still
want to account for that in my learning
problem right so I think for any of
these health problems we do want to
update under stock facilities right that
feels like a general thing that you
probably want to do uh so if you could
do this more systematically that would
be nice and then finally there's this
like really exciting human AI interviews
problem that I have no idea how to
answer uh but basically we did all this
work so that we can give people some
like allocation policy and tell them
this is what you should do right and
then the day of the allocations there
was a flood and some road is actually
like non-operational or some driver like
didn't actually show up or some truck is
missing right so they literally cannot
operationalize the thing that you told
them to do so now what do they do they
have some extra stock they kind of walk
around to every truck they see the first
truck that has some space and they just
stick it in there right uh and that's
not ideal
um and so I think this is really our
fault like we
work on these optimization problems and
they're not really like interpretable
Solutions there's been a lot of talk
about making machine learning
predictions interpretable but how do we
kind of explain like why we allocated x
per X units of you know amoxicillin to
this health facility so that they can
understand okay if I can't send it to
this place I should send it to another
place right
um I don't know the answer but if
someone does that would be great
um that's it uh thank you to my
collaborators so again Osborne Angel but
he's uh Musa Ashley and Dr Sandy secrets
[Applause]
um hi that was great I have a question
about
um sort of combining the learning
problem and the optimization problem
um in this case you had sort of like uh
you know a single nice objective and I'm
curious and this relates to the decision
tree making scenarios that you cited at
the beginning are there actually uh more
like algorithmic decision making
processes around these where it's not
just about just the single allocation
step but like maybe a more complicated
steps that you might want to apply this
sort of uh strategy to I know that makes
sense but just sort of a situation where
it's like you know if the
the city or the store has you know more
than a population of X then we do a
versus B
um uh and just like a more complicated
policy scheme where the model could be
integrated at like various steps there's
like sort of multiple options for the
intervention even though you have this
sort of single model I feel like it's
hard to like fix the optimization
problem when uh the decision-making
process is more complicated if that
makes sense than a single decision
and we always get is like oh why don't
we have a more complex objective where
we also throw in like equity and like
Logistics class Transportation costs uh
and you know complexity for like the
drivers is that what you mean that we
should have a moment not necessarily
that but just in the sense of like
um I think there's an assumption that
you're just making like a single
decision at a fixed point this is like
similar to I guess comments that Lydia
had made in her talk around just uh you
know these decisions and these policies
are not just these like single decisions
at a fixed point I think even the talk
this morning when she was talking about
like the medical decision making process
it's like right it's really this uh
decision tree right and I think that
that's why the prior work was sort of
looking at policies in the lens of that
and I'm curious if that's actually
something that shows up in this work or
if it is that simple it is this sort of
like very kind of uh one-time decision
and so you can just turn it into a
optimization problem and you can just
like integrate it like if you just
integrate your loss function into that
and it's fine or or does it actually end
up looking more complex when you try to
apply things yeah I think that's an
excellent question so like ideally we
would think about it in terms of like
this pipeline or like a reinforcement
learning like long Horizon problem I
want to say like I don't really believe
in that in this setting because there's
too much uncertainty right so they don't
even know like how much of a budget
they're gonna get next quarter like
we're operating in like these very very
uncertain environments right so how do
you plan for the future when am like not
even needing demand in this quarter
um and I have no idea if I'm going to be
demand or whether I'm going to get
donation like in code during covid like
the donation amount like you know just
came down like really largely and that's
kind of why we had this 42 unmet demand
number to start with uh so I just think
it's
I think in the US are like places where
you have like or problems where you have
better data you can think about these
longer term interventions like in
education like Lydia was talking about I
think it makes sense because we've
invested a lot to collect detailed you
know time series data I don't think
we're here yet like they only adopted
the hi is2 like 31 months ago and then
like you know half of that time nobody
was even filling out the form uh and I
don't mean that as a criticism the US
did exactly the same thing just a little
bit earlier
um and you know even here like in
impoverished neighborhoods we're not
doing a great job of doing like
integrating Ai and medicine I think
partly because we don't have like the
good panel data uh so I think we want to
get there absolutely but I I
unfortunately don't feel like we're
there yet but I think Lydia is smarter
than me so she can definitely
um chime in foreign
I had a question on your model so do you
have any assumption on the function
class of f
doesn't matter
I don't so this is a heuristic we
haven't proven anything about it but I
think F can be pretty arbitrary uh
because we're just rewriting the points
I feel like I'm gonna get yelled at for
saying that but that is my intuition
uh we haven't proven any convergence
like uh or results or anything like that
right uh but I think that's fine yeah
thank you
my questions kind of related to that
actually because
um I really like the idea of waiting the
points and I was wondering if the main
ways uh in it improves over the the like
predict and optimize approach is when
there are sub-populations yes or are are
there also other like scenarios that
don't have to do with sub-populations
where that there's an intuition for why
that works
that's a good question I even thought
about it
um I guess
thought of the sub-population example
and I thought great now they're
exclusive at least one example where
this is true uh but
yeah I think it would have to be that
you know I mean I guess it's not
necessarily so popular but it has to be
that some region of the X like the
covariate space like matters more for
decisions and I think regions of the
covariate space you can always interpret
a sub-populations so I'm not sure like
what would be more General than that
right as in not just like the individual
um points but certain subsets of
covariates or right
I think that is generalization yeah that
makes sense yeah because here it's not
like we're specifically thinking like oh
areas in the north need more or need to
be operated we're just looking for
spaces in the X like feature space right
yeah
[Music]
um um
to the point you had on the last slide
about sort of like one truck doesn't
show up that day and then you have to
like reallocate all that first of all
very funny
um
how's it feel like going to solve all
all these optimization problems like oh
it's like a Rhoda sound
um but um but it but I'm wondering
inspired by that have you thought about
robustness of these results how it's
like you know if if like one driver
doesn't show up do
would you in hindsight dramatically like
you know reallocate all the rest of the
stuff on the other tracks or kind of are
you still roughly happy with
with like the rest of the allocation
I think so I think like this seems like
a very Shadow pricey kind of problem
right like okay so we want to like think
about so so he feels like it should be
roughly monotonic because like we sent
allocations to where they were needed
most and so if you were to take away a
little bit of the budget you would just
look at wherever the next highest Shadow
price is but then you want to kind of
account for the uncertainty in the
machine learning model so maybe it's
like a shadow price plus we haven't done
any of this
um I didn't know it would be an issue
until it happened so
so that's just a random joys of practice
uh so it's just a random point in some
other
um but I I think that's sort of like
what would be ideal I think it's robust
enough like like the the existing
allocation is probably fine but when you
want to add it you want to do it in a
way that's cognizant of what the shadow
phrases are
would be my intuition I don't have
answers for any of those things that's
why I've had many exciting questions
because I don't know but but yeah
great questions
so I have one question
um so you uh you know uh take the uh the
optimization problem as an input into
the learning problem to improve the the
predictions if you thought about closing
the loop and saying can I take something
about the predictions and and improve my
Optimizer maybe the quality of
predictions at different points and and
see how that uh you know entire uh
system of feedback in both directions
works oh that's really interesting I
want to say no I mean I guess it's I
thought like because it's a stochastic
optimization problem or we're taking
into account the uncertainty of the
prediction kind of into the
objective itself that we're done that it
handles that but maybe there's something
smarter that one could do uh but to
first order we do account for the
uncertainty in any given prediction
um but I mean as you're saying that I
also feel like you know like if we were
to actually then pass that on to health
facilities and say like hey your data
would really help us improve our
predictions uh that would also be really
cool
um so this ties into your question about
how which uh which is the ways to go
after yeah
yeah
that's a great Point yeah any other
questions
wait let's thank comso again